[موسيقى]
المنطقه تزرع الرز العنبر وهو محصول يعني
نادر منه منذ عنده سنوات جرت منع للزراعه
يعني بحيث اول قبل سنتين على خمسين بالمئه
ثم اذا منع كامل هذه السنه وحتى السنه
السابقه ماكو اما بالنسبه للحمطه زرعت على
مياه قليله هي والحمد لله لكن هذا كله
يعزو الى غياب السياسي المستدامه التنميه
المستدامه مثل يجب انه تكون هناك اتفاقيه
مع الدول الجوار مثل تامين المصادر المياه
تامين المياه وتحقيق النسب المطلوبه
للزراعه للعراق وايضا الهمال الحكومي واضح
[موسيقى]
هاي عوائل فلاحيه عائشه هنا بالضيم ماي
ماكو حلاله ماكو يمشي يشتري
ماي او من الشمعه يحصل له ما يجي ابن
الحلال مات من العطش فخلي يسوونه يعني من
يصير
ويا سوريا ويصير
بمكانه يعني هاي الزراعه ما سد التعويض
ربع من التعويض هذا اللي يزرع الفلاح
يوديه والمزارع لازم اكو شيء يصير دوله
تتنوع بالنظره الصحيحه بالنظره الابويه
بالنظره المجتمع هذا التعبان مجتمع تعبان
مزارعين الفلاحين يبيع عباده وما يخلي
[موسيقى]
احنا بعد هذا لا راح العنبر ماله بديل
عندنا هنا اكثر مناطق الريفيه هاجرت
للولايه ماكو زراعه
نسبه الحلال مثل القرض احنا نطالب
بتعويضات تشلبيه قبل سنتين عوضونه واجت
على الميزانيه وعلى الميزانيه ولحد الان
كل تعويضات ماكو
ونطلب من الدوله بلكي المساعده
عدد الدولارات مثل الفيه 3000 دونهم قضاء
الهناويه زراعه الشرب